[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 136 we stand
ready to a your cues
there we go
okay we got two questions from the
discord server this week every week we
uh
ask them to provide us a question this
is the discord server you can access at
either of our patreons
and because we weren't able to do a q a
last week we we're doing two from them
this week
question number one from the discord
this week is what do you feed your cat
my vet was offended when i told her i
fed mine pumpkin mixed with a variety of
human grade meat
she claimed i needed to include grains
and recommended some brands does a grain
inclusive diet make evolutionary sense
for cats or is this paralleling some
human grade medical and corporate
incentive structures
well it is very important that your cat
abide by the cat food pyramid
cat food pyramid has meat at the very
top and then more meat and meat to meat
and meat
and then you want to give them something
to wash it down with so which might be
pumpkin could be pumpkin
yeah so i will so
the idea that a cat needs grain is
absurd
on its face
uh we in fact uh give our cats primarily
tuna and pumpkin canned tuna and canned
pumpkin we just give them a pumpkin go
at it um
and you know they don't the pumpkin
isn't something like i can leave the
pumpkin open on the counter and they
don't go for it whereas you can't leave
tuna open on the counter you kind of got
to mix it for them to eat yeah yeah
they'll eat around the pumpkin but they
don't they don't mind it but you got to
mix it in
that said
uh our 11 year old cat tesla our panther
once when he was younger got himself
locked in a neighbor's house for 10 days
the neighbor
uh was not as daft as they seem from
that story they were in fact out of town
although we did call them and we're like
is it possible our cat is like nope
certainly not anyway uh after 10 days it
became clear and i think we've said this
on air before that tesla had survived by
finding all the bread that the neighbors
had in their house and eating that
and ever since he has had a propensity
for bread and he is now an older enough
cat and was losing weight
and we have found that giving him bread
as a supplement is the easiest way to
get him to actually gain some weight
yeah
sourdough he actually prefers holla he
it's holla is his favorite it's his
favorite and
it's also toby's favorite and so toby
gets a little bit perturbed when you
come out with like a half a loaf of
sourdough that he's just gonna eat like
you have to share that with the cat so
this is all gonna be very mysterious to
people who don't understand why we are
doing things like feeding our cats tuna
which is obviously very expensive why we
would feed them pumpkin when it's not a
native part of their diet and all that
so we should probably say something
about that
a there are all sorts of pathologies
that pets are
showing with respect to their food
i now increasingly wonder about
adjuvants in the
s
conspicuously large number of
vaccinations that are being advised for
pets and whether they are triggering
food sensitivities in the same way that
i wonder if they are triggering food
sensitivities in people the suspiciously
large number of repeat vaccinations for
pets i actually i have not come yet to
question any of the particular
vaccinations i mean depending on what
your pet is and where they're being
exposed and everything
it's the
now once vaccinated they absolutely need
a yearly booster uh which you know a
good vaccine a good vaccine shouldn't
require that and this this
and i've said this here before too a
good vet said this to me a couple years
ago i was like why are you giving your
cats all the same vaccines every single
year it's a good vaccine which these are
they shouldn't you know at this point he
said you know they probably don't need
them at all ever again because they're
fully vaccinated well i don't i don't
know how to call it because it could be
that these are garbage vaccines and they
require boosters in order to be
effective i have no doubt that they are
being recommended to get vaccines that
are not in their net
interest
you know
what we know is we have an interest that
makes that we have a
uh an industry that makes money when
[Music]
people recommend or mandate that your
pets get vaccines and of course they
were abusing that so
you know that leaves us in the
predicament of not knowing
what a rational
medical program would be for your pet
but nonetheless even if it has nothing
to do with vaccines whatever it is is
causing an awful lot of pet owners to
face a situation in which
their animals become intolerant of the
food that they are eating and if you've
experienced this you know that you then
start sourcing more and more exotic
proteins that your animal is not yet
allergic to and eventually you may find
that there is nothing and your animal
will expire from its inability to
properly deal with the food that you're
giving it it's a terrible terrible fate
and as far as i know
it is largely new
so something never heard of us back in
the 70s yes that's possible we didn't
know it but there's just something about
this so anyway we have resorted to
feeding
our animals
uh something that they didn't grow up on
which was tuna
and we mix in the pumpkin because one of
our animals
our older cat tesla
has gastrointestinal issues and pumpkin
for whatever reason for both dogs and
cats
appears to be
a curative for both
too loose and
too hard stools right so a little
pumpkin we're just trying to keep keep
the gut healthy and the tuna
so we used to feed dry food but there's
a problem especially with male cats
where they get crystals in their urine
they can block
their urethra and it can actually kill a
cat if you don't catch it early
and so as a way of circumventing all of
that which of course yes it's much
cheaper to feed your animal
whatever garbage food is being
distributed even even the good stuff has
a lot of garbage in it typically
but
you know one incident where you rush
your pet to uh an emergency vet and
they're kept for 48 hours eats up many
thousands of dollars and
you know the alternative putting your
euthanizing your animal because you
can't stomach the bill is an equally
horrifying or more horrifying prospect
so
anyway
we are being proactive spending way more
than we would like to be spending on
food that we believe to be high quality
on a monthly basis having having
uh
not rushed him
to the vet or did we did we
he did go but then we are we were able
to pull him back before the
costs mounted too high
because they get them stabilized we're
like okay no they were high they wanted
to keep them for another 48 hours or
something and we were like no we can
handle it um
but
anyway so
in our cat's case tuna mixed with
pumpkin the pumpkin they don't love but
they eat and it does appear to be
healthy for them
but now you don't need to give your cats
grains they're obligate carnivores and
they have become omnivores under
their
human association
so they're capable of dealing with a lot
of stuff yep as we are yeah uh we're of
course we're omnivores humans are not
carnivores
um dogs are more omnivorous uh you know
wild wolves from which our domestic dogs
come
have a
pretty solidly meat diet but you know
all of all of our
pet carnivorous uh that we domesticate
you if you let them go outside they'll
chew on grass and such so you know
they'll they'll get some sort of fiber
in their butt in their diets yeah i
don't know that they're digesting the
grass probably not certainly not fiber
yeah
um
i will say though that the key thing to
remember when comparing dogs and cats
is
dogs have had something like 30 000
years of
uh evolution under domestication by far
the longest of any domesticated creature
the you know by three times because the
other domesticated creatures were all
subsequent to farming
dogs not they were hunting partners and
so that's an awful lot of time
to um adapt to humans obviously there
wouldn't have been a lot of grain
involved in hanging out with humans
until
farming increased this there's
yeah now and there's i mean there's
evidence i think it's in
it's in one of the chinese origins of of
agriculture places i can't remember it's
north or south and maybe one other place
where you have evidence of bread baking
many thousands of years before any
evidence of agriculture yeah so there is
grain use uh and and grain grain
preparation before agriculture but it's
not going to be at the scale yeah yeah
it was hit and miss because it's a low
predict productivity activity because
the harvesting is so hard and because
the grain itself has not evolved
to uh divide
so you throw away most of the harvested
grain it's the inedible
fiber and you recover only the the
endosperm and the point is under
domestication there's evolution for
those two things to separate cleanly
right it's in the plant's interest to
serve
the people
but before domestication it's a very
labor intensive low productivity
mode of of getting calories so anyway
dogs
most of the things that people eat and
they do pretty well on most of there are
some weird exceptions like grapes
chocolate chocolate um yeah but for the
most part
um you know grapes is a weird one
it is a weird one yeah yeah
um but anyway
um so that's the long and short of it
all right second question from the
discord this week
do you agree with ian mcgilchrist
that since the renaissance our
collective left-brained logical and
rules-based thinking has brought us to a
place where our ability to reason
intuitively has been seriously reduced
i truly wonder if it's retrievable in a
super high-tech world
i would say
it is intuitively
a match for my understanding but that
this problem has gotten
precipitously worse in the last
50 years that the degree to which people
in their ordinary interactions with the
world are not confronted by systems that
are in and of themselves sensible right
there's a certain amount of sensibleness
that arises naturally just by
interacting with
uh
you know non-computerized cars for
example um
physical systems of any sort physical
well the problem is you know a tesla is
a physical system but it's a physical
system with so much arbitrary
non-electronic yeah
pre-electronic is much more physical
so yes i would say there's a
long-standing problem and that there is
a much more precipitous more recent
problem now i don't agree
with i think this is not mcgill chris
this is the person asking the question
but i do not agree
that um it isn't reversible i think it's
readily reversible and it doesn't say
reversible he says i truly wonder if
it's retrievable in a super high tech
world well it might be about i think it
is
it is retrievable if we are deliberate
about it we know
and this is one of the things that
heather and i wrote about in our book
it's one of the things we frequently
talk about educationally but we
effectively
know what you need to be exposed to
developmentally in order to develop
those intuitions and the question is are
we going to
put kids to those tasks or are we going
to
continue to do whatever bizarre rituals
we do in school and pretend that the end
all and be-all of being smart is making
the teacher happy right
which it's not
all right
questions that came in are coming in
still at darkersubmissions.com
first question
it's at the top of the list so i'm going
to read it but i'm not totally sure
what the question means all right that's
my that's my caveat all life comes from
life
so is the environment not alive or of
life
purpose of life seems to be manipulation
at an elemental degree
free will how to get something from
nothing any thoughts how do we find
unity
yeah there's a
too many things jammed into one question
i will say
uh all life comes from life
is a great rule of thumb that cannot be
true as an actual law because obviously
that's got to start somewhere right um i
would say
defining life is tough but unimportant
it's not it's not crucial that we have
an exact boundary um but
the key thing is
which is the thing that life does that
pre-life does not
is an elaboration of something very
common in the pre-living universe
so we have selection creating patterns
and
that every everything you can see and
comprehend anything you can notice is a
pattern it's the result of some kind of
selection
that itself is not life
if you add to selection
some kind of heredity
then you get selection compounding
itself and ultimately if you get enough
of it you'll get adaptation and so the
point is that's the real distinction
between the living world and the
pre-living world is the adaptation
and so there is a hint of what becomes
adaptation which is selection
in everything else that exists absent
life but only once that process starts
self-catalyzing do you get things that
are
clearly alive
and
anyway i think that addresses at least
the first part of your question yeah i
think so too um
you know the earth
as a as a unit is not alive
uh the earth has many things in it uh
that are alive that
most observers would not recognize as
being alive
but you know the environment
what
the environment
um
taken you know
you kind of define environment but if
we're talking about for instance a
seashore an intertidal
uh environment alive not alive part of
it is a live part of it is not and so
you know the example that you have um
that you have given that is most clean
about uh the effects of selection on
non-living systems
is the way that uh the tides sort rocks
by size so that you end up um
along along a rocky seashore you can
reliably find uh you know along a um
regularly tidal rocky seashore you find
effectively
rocks sorted by size and that is a
selective process but not an adaptive
one
uh similarly though you find organisms
in the sand burrowing at different
depths
by
virtue of how long their breathing spout
is or what it is that they're eating or
you know any number of things and in
their cases that is an adaptive process
so selection in both cases adaptive in
one way the organisms are alive
non-adaptive and the other where the
things not organisms rocks for instance
are not alive
but i would say there's a confusion in
the question potentially
let's say that we took
a
ecosystem in which many things were
alive the ecosystem still isn't alive
right um because the ecosystem doesn't
adapt yeah uh so
many things in it
are alive and
don't conflate the fact that there's an
old whole lot of living stuff and some
amorphous thing as the same process yes
it's not
yeah uh
speaking of alive
there is a uh an eleven-year-old
miniature panther approaching that seems
who seems to have a lot to say yes so
apologies for those listening with cats
in their environs wondering if their
cats are talking no that's ours
uh he heard all the talk about tuna and
want some i imagine he was rather
indifferent to the talk about pumpkin
yeah dude
chill out
okay
one
is there a reason to prefer for instance
stronger symptoms over two days versus
milder milder symptoms over 10 days for
a respiratory virus like coven
or like sorry scoby2
2 we don't normally expect respiratory
viruses to peak in summer there have
been large copper 19 peaks summer each
year is this plausibly from serial
passage in a lab environment
well let's take the last one first yes i
think many of the things about the virus
that behave in a in a surprising way are
the result of the fact that we selected
presumably selected for certain things
in that environment and accidentally for
many many other things including
uh tropism
meaning a ability to infect many
different tissues ability to jump
between species yep so yes i would say
be alarmed to be very alarmed about the
fact that this thing does not behave
normally with respect to seasons it's a
troubling it's a troubling fact and it
may ultimately settle into a normal
pattern but um this this does feel like
a
a self-inflicted wound
your first question
raises
uh
very interesting
yeah i have to say raises very
interesting questions which is not a
good way to say it but but and just to
remind this is you know is there a
reason to prefer like should we should
individuals presumably have a preference
for like okay i'm gonna be really really
sick for two days or i'm gonna be a
little sick for ten
yeah my suspicion
is at the level of harm
you're dealing with
an area under the curve phenomenon where
basically the question is how net sick
were you
and that you know the same amount of
sick distributed over more time
um versus less time is equivalent and so
there's a question about
uh
there's a question about is that true
it's a question i don't think it can be
that simple though in all systems
right because for for some systems there
will be an acute there will be damage at
very sick levels that you wouldn't
experience at lower levels yeah there's
definitely a
place at which that model will break
yeah right intense enough sickness can
kill you so for example if you take a
sickness
bad enough to kill you and you
distribute it over a month rather than a
week yeah and it doesn't kill you
obviously
that's preferable right um but
then there's also the question about
what the net
immunity that is produced is
and
i can actually see arguments
in both directions
but likely the fact if it is a
pathogenic illness let's say it's a
virus that we're talking about
and you
are sick you are symptomatically sick
and you then recover that is presumably
the result of the fact that you have
successfully marshaled an immune
response and then the question is has
that immune response
triggered
memory
sufficient to fend that disease off
again and the question is is it ever
distinct such that a brief illness is
too short
to get that memory and a longer illness
even if it was less intense would have
done so or vice versa right right and i
don't know the answer but that's how i
could see it i could see it going either
way honestly yeah an intense illness
that was
very brief
it remains unclear you know why the
recovery happened but
might have been too brief to prompt
immune response and then a very low
level illness that just doesn't
none of the relevant immune
cells run into the thing
and you just
well
you know you could get a an illness that
triggered antibody response sufficient
to
[Music]
defeat it without generating t-cell
immunity for example but i i don't think
either of these things are likely
because basically
what you've got is an illness sufficient
to decrease your
capacity that is a matter of concern for
the immune system so the immune system
has every
advantage if it does learn the formula
for whatever pathogens have caused that
to happen whether it was a long or a
short illness
so i think the fact that you've gotten
sick
and then got well
pretty strongly indicates if this is a
natural pathogen that you will have
immunity to that version now it may be
that the pathogen is then so rapidly
evolving that your immunity isn't that
useful because
it's out of date a year later yep um but
but that's the basic thing yes you
probably have immunity to that disease
in either case
yeah
all right
me
so i have not seen this question before
it came in
later
me that's the wrong definition them so
what language evolves
unlike cpu programming not every
redefinition is
versioned and backwards compatible
people who redefined who redefine rather
than adding new words punish using
original derivation and thus punish
coherence and consistency it can be
intentional
is there a dictionary which cannot
deform
definitions of pre-existing words
so i think they're they're trying to
write within a
tight limit and so i was trying to make
that into full english
well
natural evolution of language must
continue to be allowed of course the
gaming of
the evolution of language for political
purposes must not be allowed
yeah and
the key you know wikipedia has the right
idea
presumably changes in wikipedia do
always leave a record
so somebody who wanted to figure out
what happened to a definition that got
politicized could in principle do so um
and you know there's no reason that in
in the electronic era
even to the extent that some definition
needs to change and you know many of our
most important definitions
change right the term gene for example
has radically shifted over our lifetime
because it had to because the original
definition was simply not up to the job
yep
but
there should be a bias against changing
definitions there should certainly be a
bias against the changing definitions uh
in the heat of a battle
right that is going to tend to be
political
and it should always leave a record so
we can retrace our steps there should
effectively be a get mode where you can
fork a definition you can go backwards
you can reestablish an earlier version
that worked
yeah that sort of thing no that's that
sounds like the right way to go about it
um
yeah i do think uh that increasingly
just as many of the trans activists have
found a few biologists who are willing
to
jump on and say oh yeah sex isn't binary
and use them as sort of you know armor
and weaponry
i think this you know so what language
evolves response uh
is also the result of
those people those sophists honestly
uh basically grabbing
linguists
um a few linguists who who are willing
to say well of course language evolves
and not sort of maybe not realize or in
a few cases maybe be interested in
helping the decay but just
you know many many good people will
think that they are
uh
standing strong for something that is
actually obvious within their field
uh language evolves without realizing
they are actually being used as a tool
in a battle they did not wish for right
i think i got it
this is one of those cases where we say
evolves when what we mean is adapts
and the point is
language
adaptation should increase
the utility of language
too often what happens is because it's
politicized it decreases the utility of
language we lose the ability to say
basic things that we could say before
and that that is the hallmark of bad
evolutionary trends
right
um
it's like linguistic
eugenics
selecting for certain uses of terms that
serve their interests rather than that
serve us collectively and communicating
okay so take that
wow yeah well you got tesla's attention
yes well yes i did okay
um
i saw a video of a clam swimming found
it cute
also there's a sea snail that
incorporates iron into its shell and
survives temperatures above 700 degrees
fahrenheit
in the shade
no
any favorite bivalves or bivalve facts
now wait a minute
do you know of clam swimming i certainly
know scallops doing it is a scallop not
a kind of clam well that's a good
question a snail's not a bible right no
a snail is a mono valve yeah
um
but a clam is a clam is a bivalve a
scallop is a bi valve is a scallop a
clam and is this person therefore
justified if that what they saw was
indeed a scallop swimming and they are
cute when they do it yeah um
or have they
aired slightly i don't think it much
matters let's assume that i don't know i
i know very little about my invertebrate
um
invertebrate phylogeny
um
yes
well first a first look suggests
that while both
by valves not necessarily
in the same group
i'm just going to go a little deeper
here i'm going to go a little deeper
yeah yeah
we are going to find out whether or not
there is a
branch of the
no i'm in you know the famous journal
molecular marine biology and
biotechnology here with the comparison
of moleskine phylogeny is based on
paleontological molecular data but it's
it's going to take me a little time
really to yeah
yeah yeah because i just don't i just
don't know the groups we're talking
about
um but really back in
93 you already had fully
sequenced that seems probable
well anyway oh wait no just the the 18s
rrna gene from three scallop species and
seven matric clam species have been
fully sequenced just one gene this that
that's that sounds like the 90s yeah
yeah i remember that yeah no totally
photogenic analysis support the scheme
of waller for the pectin a day but
conflict would but conflict with current
evolutionary concepts and classification
within the factory day
um so at least
yeah at at least as of
a long time ago at this point um early
mid 90s
you had them being sister but distinct
sister but distinct which raises the
very question we just talked about last
time
totally um
so what you probably saw was a scallop
swimming
and that is not technically a clam
though you could make an argument
for the whole group being clams
which wouldn't change the biology in any
case maybe what you saw was a clam
swimming and we don't know about that
behavior in which case i'd love to see
it if their sister yes you could
similarly make an argument for the whole
group being scallops
oh yes equally so equally so and all you
got to do is figure out which of these
things
you're going to stick with and make it
clear to everybody what you've done and
it's biologically all right yes
yeah
any favorite buy valves or buy bell
facts
favorite yeah that's what the question
actually was the the the most moderate
here did not wish to be challenged on uh
his or her uh phylogenetic analysis
really yeah really i think i think they
that's right can take it
um favorite bible i mean probably it is
the scallop on or the scallop
the scallop the mighty scout saying the
bat um
probably worse than saying the bat oh no
i no
i i think knowing very little about
invertebrate
biologics that there are more species of
bath than there are of scallops really
that's yes i do more than a thousand
species of scallop no i think the
opposite i think there are more species
of bats than there are of scallop you
were arguing that there are more species
of scallops than there are bats right
right i spoke wrongly but i knew what
you said yeah i agree but i i agree with
about what you said i think there are
likely to be more scallop species than
than bats but this is scallop sensu
strict you're not including the clams no
including the clams and the scallops i
would not do that now
30 seconds ago but
um
and i am prepared to be embarrassed on
that front
um which i think it's not going to be
ever close
really yeah just because they all taste
alike i doubt we eat more than a couple
of species i really don't know like i
said you know we're just
neither of us does invert systematics
yeah at all really yeah i mean
a little bit over in in
in insect land but a lit just a little
bit yeah uh
so yeah probably
the scallop on the basis of the swimming
that the scallop does so compellingly
they just have oodles of character they
do they do have oodles of character i
yeah i wish something was jumping to
mine nothing is
uh so you know ask again maybe we'll
have thought about this yeah that's the
sort of thing i'd like to be thinking
about
but
anyway
oh
summer has me wondering about the
evolution of throwing so many sports are
based on it hopefully this isn't a
softball question for you
ouch i hear ya ouch
um
well
one thing we can say for sure
is that non-ape monkeys aren't going to
be very good at throwing
non-ape monkeys
i see why yeah you do i think but do
they i think you do i think i do i think
you do you want to you want to say it
you want me to go there well i'm going
to i'm going to i'm going to go out on a
limb
oh god okay is it because uh the apes
are the uh the brachiators yeah yeah we
can do this yeah
yeah so that includes gibbons and
other gibbons and more gibbons and
including the cyman which is the biggest
gibbon and then the great apes
of which
uh we are we're closely related to that
glade so the orangs uh the gorilla and
the two chimpy species and then they are
great
yeah they are great
so anyway but then everything all the
other so we're also monkeys though right
like we're monkeys we're apes we're
great apes for
homonyms
so yeah this the the brachiation um
which is an ape synapomorphy that is to
say a shared derived characteristic that
um that shows up at the level of of apes
allows for the hand over hand stuff that
you see um and you know other the other
monkeys don't have that they don't they
don't have the ability to do as much of
that although we tend to think of
monkeys kind of swinging through the
trees now
16 dozen different complaints come to
mind okay one
they should be eight bars not monkey
bars true although
so the problem is all apes are monkeys
but
by calling the monkey bars we expect
that any monkey could do it and
certainly many monkeys cannot however
there are monkeys in our experience new
world monkeys new world monkeys that do
something that looks to me like
radiation yeah i think
you know i haven't i haven't thought
about this in a while
and i think the answer is that they they
do a sort of a thing i i suspect that
they're doing more like this rather than
actually swinging that this you know the
something in the shoulder the something
in the
uh the pectoral girdle and like the
rotator cuff allows for this this entire
thing which is then going to be related
to throwing right yeah which is why
we're on this topic um whereas if you
look at say a spider monkey yeah um uh
they're going to be doing they're going
to be doing more like this
and you know maybe as much of this but
maybe it's that that they can't do i'm
not even positive i think i've got
pictures of them doing something that
looks very much yeah i mean they did
definitely because they've got
spiders in particular spider monkeys
have that prehensile tail yeah you know
as does that whole little clade of of
i can't remember the name of the the
clade within the clade of new world
monkeys that has the pre-insult tail
they spent a lot of time hanging from
one two three four five of their limbs
effectively the fifth being their tail
um they do not throw things with their
tail though
never seen it never seen it i did once
have one come up around me yeah and put
its tail over your shoulder yes that was
a very friendly that was the last monkey
in copan that's right in honduras the
southernmost uh known city of the maya
when we were there in the early 90s all
right question now this person did not
know that they were ruining a perfectly
good joke by
saying softball question
but the point that you are making about
brachiation being a precondition of
quote-unquote throwing
so monkeys
monkeys can throw like a girl
but you need no but they could throw
underhand like softball
oh
yeah that's in that's interesting yeah
yeah i can't not but not with those
chairs this room but um but yeah so
anyway uh
probably the
the apes uh and the brachiation is a
precondition for overhand throwing which
is really the good throwing yeah now i
mean probably uh
i
i can't
at the moment i'm not seeing a lot of
necessity for like throwing
gourds and vegetables and other dug
things at one another and for and that
would probably be more of a short
shorter underhanded thing anyway
um so it's about it's going to be about
hunting yeah you know the original rocks
rocks
sure like hurt maybe herding animals
like off a cliff and then and then with
pointed sticks yeah and pointed rocks
right right look it takes a very special
cognitive model to get it right i mean
if you think about that's funny i uh i
remember making this argument in adrian
zillman's class a class i failed um
a class whose the narrative description
your narrative evaluation which i
recently found recently on earth yes
yeah
it's quite something the point is
throwing throwing accurately
is a
pretty remarkable skill
because somehow you are taking an object
and let's say that you've got a whole
pile of rocks you can pick up
six rocks in a row they don't weigh the
same amount and you're gonna fit in the
hand exactly the same way right they're
in no way identical and you can
throw in such a way that you hit the
same target right so what exactly do you
have to know what do you have to be able
to infer when you pick that up do you
have to know its weight does
accelerating your arm a certain amount
mean that you don't need to know its
weight that it is empirically corrected
for anyway it's a it's an interesting
skill and you need a model yeah
for
basically space well beyond you
and
uh
and objects and how they're going to
behave you need the developmental
experience of how different objects
behave when you throw them
and uh
clearly there's been a whole lot of
selection to get us both to
be able to model it and to be rewarded
for doing it right little boys love to
throw things and you know hit a target
you know throwing up so do some little
girls it's true non-gender conforming
little girls and and little boys uh you
throw a stick in the river and the stick
floats down river and throwing rocks at
it is just you know wow is that fun it
is it is and it doesn't hurt anyone
except the occasional fish you bonk on
the head yeah that they were probably
asking for it i'm sure they are yeah
most fish are yeah most fish probably
are yep
i don't know why i said
okay this next question
i'm sure is
excellent given who is asking it but i'm
having a little bit of a hard time
parsing it so i'm going to give it a
first pass and then you'll see if you
can help me out here
on the mountain of mass formation it
seems isaac might be spared from being
stabbed by the jab thanks to religious
exemption the use of aborted fetal cells
abortion unlawful
cf the chicago north shore university
health system settlement
and i don't think i know i don't think i
am aware of the chicago north shore
university health system settlement
this is echo yeah
i really wish i could pick up the
context of uh of that question
um
communicate with us separately and uh
we'll come back to this next week right
and i would say two things are necessary
here one is the ability to parse the
question and the other is the ability to
cut the question to the relevant bits
which is like a parse snip
seasonally inappropriate what
seasonally
man
parsnips are good in any season harder
to source in some seasons than others
hence inappropriate
wow
um i'm guessing i don't know but i'm
guessing a parsnip is a biennial and so
the proper season is gonna be the fall
is that right yeah
yeah and you know if you've got a good
good root seller you can eat them into
the winter yeah but they're not summer
now
a good root seller well
we
we have well he's got a good selection
his prices aren't that great but
it's
spelled differently wow
what a bummer
homosexuality in the animal kingdom
question mark if true is it just that
humans have witnessed highly active sex
drives and certain animals
no um
so this is a this is an important
distinction
yes there's lots of homosexual behavior
in the animal kingdom lots and lots and
lots and lots and lots what there isn't
is obligate homosexuality
especially uh
in
well actually i think in either sex
um
it's the obligate homosexuality which is
peculiar to humans
well i can think of one exception to no
obligate homosexuality
um which is in
the
pneumodophorous the whiptail lizards
that have gone asexual it's not it's not
obligate
it is obligate because only very
occasionally on um between generations
not every individual right right right
you know so it's public for whole
generations for whole life spans for
whole
coteries of mothers and daughters and
granddaughters etc um
to to engage in pseudocopiatory behavior
with other females in order to induce
egg uh like follicle
production
and egg release in order to have um
asexual parthenogenetic children i will
grant that your example is an obligate
one but it is a an exception that proves
the rule this is what exception improves
the rule actually means despite how
people abuse that term but the point is
in that case
is it obligate well
it's obligate
um
but there's an escape hatch as there is
with all of these parthenogenic
creatures
and the escape hatch is periodic sexual
reproduction
every so many generations
so all right cool
oh was there more to the question yeah
he wants to know about homosexuality in
the animal kingdom
so however you want to say the usual
thing you say okay here i'll give you a
personal example
um i was collecting lizards in jamaica
my first research gig was uh researching
lizards in jamaica there are something
like six
species of uh
animals what we're called animals
they're now norops
they're still no lids i believe and
either
yeah i don't know anyway um so i was
collecting them keeping them in
captivity trying to see what i could
figure out about them
and i had captured the largest species
is this bright green very large
animal
and i had captured
one and i had it in captivity and it
wasn't doing great so i released it and
i released it on a tree that i did not
realize was the territory of another
male
and
the animal
ran up the tree as i released it and the
other
the male that owned the tree immediately
copulated with it
um
so anyway yeah there's lots of
homosexual behavior
that's different than homosexual
creatures yep yep
okay this i believe is a question from
last week because we there some
questions came in it's not a question
it's a comment based on our conversation
about flies
and isopropyl yeah draw the flies into a
bathroom with a light then close the
door
that's how you collect them yeah so you
concentrate that's how you yes yes
um
is having your immune system compromised
by the cobot vaccine the biggest or most
common adverse effect since it seems to
be affecting most of the vaccinated
thank you and much love
which is a lot we don't know yeah if the
question is is it the most common effect
i think almost certainly by virtue of
the fact that it seems to be
if not a universal consequence of at
least the mrna vaccines a near universal
one yeah so biggest and common are
actually distinct enough here um you
know the question is asked almost as if
those are synonyms but like most common
seems to be so
like nearly universal so presumably yes
biggest
probably not okay it can't be
biggest because because there are you
know as with as with any medical
intervention sometimes you know you'll
die people die yeah which is yeah that
really gets in the way of the rest of
your life it does yeah
yeah
okay
as an atheist and a scientist why do you
believe humans have free will do you
think other things might have it
what is its mechanism in origin is it
simply an emergent property
simply an immersion property
it's not a stupid
property
well as opposed to an adaptation
so well
adaptations can be emergent
adaptation is a an emergent process but
when they say it's like is it a
coincidence or is it simply a
coincidence right
an emergent property could be that you
take you know two things that have never
been together before and you put them in
the same place and it creates some
thing that wasn't your intention
an adaptation is something that's been
favored for
the fact that it had this property so
the question is is free will there as a
byproduct or is free will there okay as
an adaptive
force
so
i think this question
is simpler than most people think
that effectively
the
a universe in which we don't have any
free will
is a universe that does not make sense
and it's not that it couldn't exist it's
not that some alien race couldn't have
created a
uh
computer program in some elaborate
computer environment in which we all
walked around with the illusion that we
had free will but were absolutely
trapped and the illusion was for
they
wanted us to have it for some reason yep
that's completely inconsistent with
evolution
we have a subjective experience of the
universe we often have two things in
front of us and we
debate which thing to choose sam harris
would say yes but what are you choosing
on the basis of you're choosing on the
basis of values and fears and things
like that and those things come from
somewhere so are you really free and my
answer to this which i believe i lost
the argument to sam when sam was on
dark horse though i still think he's
wrong i think he won the argument
because he's a very formidable debater
and
his point is not um
without there are many uh meritorious
points along the way though i think his
conclusion is wrong but um
the
fact
of evolution
requires
different outcomes to be possible
that a universe in which every outcome
of every interaction was preordained
from the first moments of the universe
is not a sensible universe because there
would be no reason for evolution to
create the appearance of competition
right
and so the point is
if there's no if we live in a completely
deterministic universe
then all the outcomes are preordained
the terror that a creature feels as it
runs away from its predator is pointless
if it's just a means to an end to get it
to unsuccessfully run away right so my
point is look
i can't say for sure that we don't live
in a deterministic universe but i can
say that a deterministic universe would
be a very bizarre one it would be much
more bizarre than one in which for
whatever reason heisenberg presumably
there is variability in what can happen
it wasn't all preordained
and one of the manifestations of this is
free will in which we are actually able
to choose however
the fact that there
to me appears to be free will
actual free will at our disposal does
not say that there is nearly as much of
it as people think
right we are not
very free so i think sam harris has a
point
which is that we are highly highly
constrained
and i agree with him in that
but we are not totally constrained and
that's the question is is the amount of
free will not very much or is it zero
and my answer would be a universe in
which it's zero would be a very strange
place indeed
it would make a mockery of subjective
experience there'd be no point in having
it
um
but uh you know that doesn't nail it
down that just says
uh you've
it says that the the argument that we
have no free will is a philosophical
loser because it makes a more
complicated universe rather than a less
complicated universe
right it's it's an occam's
razor failure
yeah i think that's right and um
actually the next question
fits with that
you confer supreme agency to evolution
to the point of anthropomorphization
which i mispronounced but why
and so a i would say no no we don't um
but uh
but
the reason it might look that way
is precisely one in which if you are if
you are not averse
to complexifying your explanations of
the universe you might see um evolution
as a kind of you know an
antimorphization of of the systems that
it's explaining and you know no actually
occam's razor suggests that um that this
is what explains what we're seeing
and it's it's the opposite of
anthropomorphization i can't even say it
okay it's misspelled as part of why like
i have the visual and i can't look at
that because it's there's a bunch of
letters missing anthropomorphization
yeah which sounds wrong it sounds like
there's a syllable it's not a it's not a
well-honed word yeah um
i would argue that central to this is a
language problem okay
our language was built
to do things like explain human
motivations it was not built to explain
processes like evolution
it is almost impossible if you relegate
yourself to explaining evolution as it
actually happens without
anthropomorphizing
you will talk yourself in circles trying
to say perfectly obvious things oh i see
okay so there will there will be
an appearance of ascribing intent to
evolution and you know for a while you
know when we're actually teaching a
class for a while we'll say you know i'm
going to use the shorthand and you know
and we don't anymore because you just
you can't every time you get up right
and dawkins has this right he says
it is important that you are always able
to go from your shorthand version back
to the rigorous version if you need to
but if you think about it you know if
you say
even something obvious like
you know
uh a tree
has leaves to capture sunlight right
that sounds like the tree is trying to
catch something country's not trying to
do anything the point is
the ancestors of the tree that happened
to have
cells with photosynthetic capacity
arrayed in a way that
fell where the sunlight
came through the canopy had more
chemical energy at their disposal even
the word disposal i've now tripped over
it again
yeah but it's also i mean it's frankly
it's also anthropomorphic to say that
that language is anthropomorphic because
it's imagining that anything with desire
or anything with consciousness is a
human is a human thing
so it's you know it's it's actually
revealing the self-centeredness the
anthropomorphic nature of the person
accusing the explanation of being
anthropomorphic very often well really
it's a blind watchmaker issue which is
that
you know the blind the watchmaker is
blind
right that's kind of the point is that
when you find a watch in the ground it
implies a watchmaker in this case the
watchmaker is actually a process that is
blind um and
in this case the point is
you will do far you will understand far
more about the strange and lovely world
that you've been born into
if you allow yourself
to imagine that creatures are trying to
get their genes into the future for
example right it is very efficient and
intuitive to say that essentially all of
the patterns that are common to
creatures right if you see a species of
tree that typically has
a tendency to do x y and z that it is
doing that to get its genes into the
future you will be far better off just
allowing yourself to say that even
though it's not precise right then yep
preventing yourself from saying you'll
be far more confused if you hold
yourself to
saying only things that are perfectly
precise and true
so something like that good
okay if climate change is driven by
solar and geologic activity rather than
human action what do we do then
say we spend 100 trillion dollars
globally on fusion but it's still 100
plus years away what then
monetary waste matters too wait can you
go back to the beginning of the question
if climate change is driven by solar or
geological activity rather than human
action what do we do then
well here's
here's the way i would parse the
question
if it is due
to long-standing processes that are
really not about people
that's good news
okay because
what it means is the really frightening
ways this could unfold like the
clathrate gun hypothesis
are unlikely to because the earth will
already have been through this
if this is human generated and therefore
novel
i will say you know but
there have you know we are in
what is this in the sixth
major extinction event
on earth so the earth having been
through this whatever this is
again does not necessarily mean that
life can mostly survive it even even if
the climate change that is actually
truly being observed were not
anthropogenic it depends what those what
those uh previous extinctions were right
i mean if they're
comets from outer space that's a very
different
puzzle
yeah
this very little suggestion that all
five of the previous major extinction
events no they weren't but the question
is were they the result of an ongoing
fluctuating process or were they the
result of some sort of catastrophic
breakage in the normal
right
if climate change is the result of
fluctuations that are always ongoing and
they're ongoing now then the point is
we've got a system that is robust to
those things
it is not robust to a comet coming out
of nowhere
right because i mean i guess you're
picking
it could be solar or geological activity
that's not just ongoing stuff but but
that is that very unlikely
that's that's why it's not impossible
that there could be a new geological
process but what are the chances or not
just not new but you know just a uh a
periodic an episodic thing
if it is a periodic episodic thing that
happens then the point is the system is
built for it
it is the novelty that is the hazard and
the novelty can be natural novelty in
the form of
uh an object from deep space or it can
be human generated novelty
but that's the thing to fear and so the
reason that i do fear the human
[Music]
generated climate change has to do with
frozen methane in the arctic the chances
that we get to some point at which it
starts self-facilitating its own release
and that the amount of it that gets
released in that positive feedback
process is so great that would it
doesn't leave a functional world right
i think that that's
pretty likely
and so what it means is we should work
very hard to control it now the problem
is that there's an artificial dichotomy
in the question as it's been posed
which is
because the chemistry
right the chemistry of of global warming
is very simple it's a very long-standing
uh
piece of knowledge and very easily to
easy to demonstrate that co2 and methane
trap heat right so
let's say that we've got a solar process
which we undoubtedly do doesn't mean
that it's in that phase now but we've
got a solar process that's natural and
fluctuating we've got geological
processes that are natural and
fluctuating
and we've got humans mucking about
releasing millions of years worth of
stored carbon in you know in a couple of
centuries
right those things compound each other
and so the point is maybe the natural
part of it
is something that would produce a
tolerable effect but the compounded
nature of those things combined might go
somewhere new and function like you know
like a an object from deep space
indeed
all right how long have we been at a sec
uh
just about an hour okay let's do it we
get a lot of questions uh let me do a
couple more okay
uh
first couple comments here eerie there
was a murder in my town a couple of days
ago a young guy who had been arrested
and released a number of times
uh next comment i got my pfizer shirt in
the mail this morning and joe biden test
positive for coven 19 again i guess the
breakthroughs never stop
thanks
look up wikipedia is a tertiary
look up wikipedia is a tertiary source
primary sources are original research
secondary sources are reliable sources
which is the same thing as mainstream
media wikipedia rules let it write only
about what appears in
reliable sources when therefore captured
that's interesting that is interesting
um
what do you make of so many monkey pox
survivors being hiv positive 41
or on
prep which i looked up that's
pre-exposure prophylaxis which the
person writing the question says is 74
percent
so again what do you make of so many
monkey poc survivors being hiv positive
41 or on pre-exposure
prophylaxis exposure to hiv
hiv pre-exposure prophylaxis yeah um so
i don't that that may just be consistent
with
uh this is about this is about gay men
yeah right this is this is a this is uh
transmitting through
homosexual male sex like we know other
like like hiv does right um so
that that seems like the most likely
thing um but obviously the person asking
the question is
intimating that there might be a
relationship with exposure either to hiv
or to whatever is in the pre-exposure
yeah phylaxia now those are obviously
statistically separable
if you set out to test it it's very easy
100 but i don't like i've never seen
these numbers before i don't know what
those numbers mean so i think neither
you or i
want to touch it until we've seen
whether those numbers are
general correlations or whether they
have already completed the most obvious
totally separable but the most obvious
hypothesis until we know is that this is
just about this in fact being you know
a
virus that is most easily transmitted
through gaseous is a highly non-random
virus and therefore is going to find
other patterns right
lodging genes in the future is a side
effect
people want children over clones or
immortality genes really want relative
improvement and then we got a winky
smiley face
i think it's i think it's sort of
tongue-in-cheek it's tongue-in-cheek
look
lodging genes in the future
is in its own way a side effect but the
point is
almost all
of your cognitive processes
which are the core of your life
right produce that as a byproduct and
the weird thing is to recognize that
that byproduct effect is the entire
reason that adaptation created those
structures
yeah
okay we got uh three more questions and
we've got a lot more than that randy
three more
when and why did monogamy become a thing
in the human race
love you both
well i'm gonna make my uh my argument
for this
monogamy is an adaptation to certain
conditions as is polygony
right as is promiscuity now the question
is are the conditions
present that favor this
now what i would argue is that monogamy
was
definitely not the most common system
but that it became arguably the most
common system that is to say most people
are live in societies that are at least
nominally monogamous none of those
societies are perfectly monogamous as no
animal that we know of that is
monogamous is perfectly monogamous
and indeed in non-human animals uh
researchers
uh who study this sort of thing always
uh talk about the separation between
genetic and social monogamy uh right you
know there's there's often near perfect
social monogamy and still one or both
partners
in this species will tend to cheat um
genetically yep yeah
okay so
the argument though is
what would favor
the
elaboration of monogamy the spreading of
monogamy and i will argue
it is
rapid population growth when lineages
are competing with each other
the expansion of a lineage favors
monogamy because
other systems sideline most males from
contributing to the raising of offspring
the thing that limits how fast a
population can grow is how many adults
are contributing to the extremely
expensive process of raising human
babies
monogamy brings the maximum number of
those
adults into the process because they
have a genetic interest in contributing
and so i would argue it is no accident
that the age of exploration
saw the flourishing of monogamous
lineages which spread and had their
populations massively increase on for
example new land masses and so the
pattern the prediction
is that anywhere in history in
prehistory and in human pre-history that
we see a population go through rapid
expansion you will see a tendency
towards monogamy at the point that
carrying capacity for whatever land mass
or
opportunity has already has been reached
you will see the breakdown in that
monogamy i believe that's where we are
now and it's part of why we're seeing
all of the craziness around sex that we
are seeing
and
the
uh
final piece of that argument is that
actually monogamy whether or not it is
the best way to get your genes into the
future whether or not we are in an
expansion phase or a stable phase
is still the best thing for civilization
it's the best system
for people it is the best system for
children
and so
we should be seeking to stabilize
monogamy even if we have reached the
phase in
population uh
growth that would ordinarily cause it to
break down
good
dr candace neyman age 27 was the fifth
toronto doc to die this month
she died after collapsing during a
triathlon
can we ask some questions now
i saw this
the other four were all male doctors
a little older than her at least a
couple of them were late 40s 50.
um
but all of them appeared to be in very
good health
and in no case can you say uh one no one
of them might have been
one of them might have had cancer
actually
uh but sorry but nonetheless we're stuck
in the problem where
in any particular case you could have a
freak occurrence there would be more
than one maybe all of them but
the chances that this is anomalous are
pretty high and what we're being
prevented from doing is rigorously
addressing the question and i will say
that the pattern
if you take the hypothesis
that we deployed
some months ago about why the mrna
vaccines in particular were likely to
cause
myocarditis that basically because they
get taken up arbitrarily by cells that
were never intended to take them up
those cells get targeted by the immune
system because the immune system
mistakes them for virally infected cells
immune system kills those cells
that is basically going to be necrotic
damage
to whatever organ it's happened in if
it's a little necrotic damage in your
liver you probably get away with it if
it's a little necrotic damage in your
heart you may get away with it but let's
say you're an athlete
you've got a little necrotic damage in
your heart because the vaccine got taken
up by some heart cells
you do okay until you push yourself past
some limit that you haven't seen in the
last
year yep and the point is oh that's a
limit beyond which you can't you can't
function
and this would be the pattern you would
see both people
anomalously dying yeah just at points
that are inexplicable and you would see
athletes dying
during competition yep during a
triathlon 27 year old extremely healthy
extremely active
young woman
yup died during a triathlon it's tragic
it is it's tragic and obviously and only
an insane society wouldn't be interested
in figuring out if there was a pattern
because the the news article i read
about it um some toronto newspaper uh
simply had a
like a one sentence press release from
the hospital uh saying it's not related
to the vaccine like
it isn't it now right yeah like that
that's that's the thing you need to
communicate and i know what basis could
you possibly know on what basis could
you possibly know and how many people
are you gonna put in jeopardy like
because if this is what's going on right
it is almost certainly true
that there's some period of time over
which you are maximally vulnerable right
and that there's a way even if you've
had this damage that you could
rationally approach your life that would
reduce the chances that you don't
survive
and the problem is if you tell people
oh that person died it had nothing to do
with the vaccine that you also got then
they will not have the rational response
which is is there anything i can do can
i mitigate the risks to myself or is
that not part of a public health policy
right exactly really
um final question is it true that the
chupacabra is the descendant of a wolf
and coyote
i've never heard this before
a wolf in kite what does that have to do
with a goat i don't know what's a goat
eater
she's a goat sucker oh sucker yeah
um as a goat sucker you're right it is
draining goats of blood oh yeah then
definitely
um yeah i've never heard that before but
um i mean what are they called
kai wolves coy wolves that sounds like a
fish koi um exist so i mean we know that
they came red wolf
what
red wolf is so what the the suggestion
here was the hybrid between a wolf and a
coyote yeah yeah isn't that it's not the
explanation for red wolves i don't know
i don't know i think it is i mean
c-o-y-w-o-l-f i don't know how to
pronounce it is like a known hybrid
thing
well it is possible that i'm going to
get caught off guard by the biology that
i paid incomplete attention to but i
believe that red wolves
are now understood to be the result of a
hybridization event and i thought it was
between wolves and coyotes
we are now some scientists believe that
the red wolf which once around much of
the southeast is in fact a coyote hybrid
with wolves and a separate species all
right some scientists
some of them are sitting next wait are
these scientists who distribute mal
information or are these
blue team sanctioned scientists how much
consensus do they believe in
wow and do they follow the economics
um so what i'm finding in google scholar
is um that red wolves and coyotes can
hybridize and also that red wolves and
wolves can hybridize both of which
suggest something although if we also
separately know that wolves and coyotes
can hybridize it doesn't necessarily say
anything
i thought this was oh here we go nailed
down uh
the problematic red wolf oh no that's
published in scientific american people
up here yeah i know isn't that great the
red wolf is not a hybrid we have from
conservation biology in
1992.99 i'm talking about more recent
stuff than that
yeah i don't know
i thought this was nailed down in the
early 2000s
dynamics of hybridization introgression
and red wolves and coyotes
i don't know man
all right well
reviving ghost alleles genetically
admixed coyotes along the american gulf
coast are critical for saving the
endangered red wolf
yeah
yeah
so it does raise a question chupacabra
um
so chupacabra for those unfamiliar
is well i actually i've never run into
it until we started traveling in latin
america um is is a story of a
of a monster that roams at night and uh
is is scary and dangerous an
exsanguinating monster exaggerating
blood
free corpses
mostly of goats countryside yep yes
mostly i mean you know but used to scare
children yeah sure it's not a very nice
story no
so eat your vegetables
there it is i think that did it yep yeah
that's it that's that's the way that
brett is now going to end all of these
episodes so
so
eat your vegetables eat your vegetables
you know i i wouldn't mind having a
catchphrase but i don't think that can
be it no no no i don't think i don't
think so so we will be back next week
join us then
who knows what will have happened by
then yeah it's really hard to say
probably everything probably everything
will have happened by then
uh in the meantime consider joining us
uh at my patreon tomorrow uh sunday july
20 20 july 31st
at 11 a.m we'll be doing a private q a
and we'll leave it up for those of you
who have joined to listen to afterwards
if you can't join us live join brett's
patreon uh at one of the higher dollar
events
and just uh generally be present and
share what we're doing here with other
people if you think that they can handle
it yeah do the thing and do it well
no it's not good
all right
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you